[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER:
Welcome to this session
about CI/CD and serverless
and multi-environments.
This is a topic that we are
very passionate about because we
have seen that good CI/CD
makes a big difference,
makes all the difference,
when it comes to dev velocity
in an organization.
My name is Martin Omander,
and I am a Developer Advocate
in Google Cloud.
ADAM ROSS: And I am Adam Ross.
I'm an engineer and Developer
of Relations in Google Cloud.
How many of you have ever
deployed to production
from a documented checklist?
Raise your hands.
Oh, it's still a large
number of people.
OK, how many of you
built a CI/CD pipeline
to automatically run
tests or deployments?
Also a lot.
MARTIN OMANDER: That's
good, a lot of people.
ADAM ROSS: Yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: Excellent.
ADAM ROSS: Well,
today, we're going
to explore one particular
organization's journey
into building their own
pipeline for automating
these serverless operations,
Into the Woods Camping Supply.
And before we get too
far, you should know
that this is a made up company.
They're imaginary, but they've
got some real world problems
that we've seen actual
organizations face.
And as we go through their
decision-making process
and their solutions, you
might see some things
that you can bring back
to your own organization
as solutions to your problems.
MARTIN OMANDER: It's a
shame they are imaginary.
They have such a
stylish catalog.
ADAM ROSS: Yeah, well, yeah.
I don't know.
That's the wrong shade of red.
But one of their
problems is they've
had slower and slower
release velocity because they
don't have a good automation
pipeline in place.
So they don't really know
when things go wrong,
and when they do, they
need to go spelunking
into the depths of
their code changes
to find out how to fix it.
So their existing architecture
has one monolithic application
and a number of
microservices, each of them
built as a serverless service.
And they need to
figure out, how do
we approach these
individual services
and modernize how
they're operated?
We're going to go straight to a
demo on what they end up doing
by walking through a change.
So the new engineering manager
has the friendly failures
initiative, which requires
that all the error
messages be friendlier.
And we change.
And let's go ahead and
create a quick branch.
Stage that code.
Commit.
I hope.
Let's watch conference
Wi-Fi in action.
That was really fast.
OK.
So now, we're going to open
a merge request in GitLab.
GitLab is the version
control platform
of choice for Into the Woods.
GitHub and Bitbucket
are all great products,
this just happens to be
what Into the Woods uses.
And here, we're going to
open a merge request, which
is roughly the same
concept as a pull request.
So now that I've opened
this merge request,
it immediately
shows us a nice page
that has the ability
to open in Web ID,
check out the branch
to explore it.
But most particularly,
we see this blue circle
here next to a pipeline.
A pipeline is the
set of jobs that
are run to ensure the quality
and deployment process,
and that's
automatically kicked off
as soon as I open
that merge request.
And we can dig into that
and see what it's doing.
So here, we have a
visualized display
of different stages
for this pipeline,
running from testing all the
way up through deployment
and acceptance.
And we're going to go deeper
into the individual stages
for this later.
Drilling into just
one of these, we
see that there's a linting
job for the payment process,
and it's taking a little time
to initialize this workspace,
check out the code,
authenticate G Cloud.
And oh, I have an error.
Well, that's unfortunate.
I guess I should
fix that problem.
And I also left a comma
in the wrong place.
So now that I've made
a couple of fixes here,
I'll commit that.
And we should see a new
pipeline running through.
I'm going to just
take a quick look
and make sure it's running.
Yeah.
While that cooks, we'll
go ahead and move along.
Can we go back to the slides?
MARTIN OMANDER:
So ops automation,
one might think it's
about computers,
but I'm here to tell
you it's about humans.
And we all have our different
views of automation.
Junior James, he is a
pretty junior developer at
Into the Woods.
He just wants to avoid
frustration and bureaucracy,
just bang out his code
and deploy it and have
it be tested and have it work.
Process Pari.
Pari, she's into
processes and scripts.
She has this idea
of ops automation
should be about reducing
manual toil for the developers.
Teamwork Tess, she
focuses on teamwork,
and she wants everybody to
have confidence in the code
and bring relief to the team.
And finally, the fourth
person in the engineering team
here is Sang.
He's the CTO.
He wants to make it
really clear to everybody
what they're supposed to
do as part of a release.
And we'll see these
four engineers here.
They are going to discuss
and build a CI/CD pipeline,
and we'll see the final
result at the end of the talk.
So they will have to go
through various things.
There are six major
decisions that they
will need to make from
repo layout, all the way
to security.
And they'll discuss, see pros
and cons of various approaches,
and arrive at a
solution for each one.
Repo layout, first one--
it's foundational.
Before you do this,
you can't really
do any of the other pieces.
There are various ways you
can do repo management.
So for example,
Junior James, he's
heard a lot about microservices
and being super agile,
and he's like one repo
per microservice, right?
They keep everything light
and really truly separated,
these microservices.
Pari notes that there is
some integration tests.
Where would they live?
Tess notes that there are
some code calling each other
across microservices.
Where would the API
specs for that live?
Also, Pari right notes
that sometimes they
need to run shared tools
across the codebase.
That's really easier with a
monorepo, single code base.
And this is, of course,
easier to sharing knowledge.
So after some discussion,
James is convinced,
OK, let's try the
monorepo approach.
What would that look like?
The layout might be
something like this.
Some files in the root, some
docs folder and test folder.
We have the monolith.
They are moving from the
monolith to microservices.
The monolith is still there, so
microservices are still there.
One director for the monolith,
one services directory
with all the different
microservices,
have their own subdirectories.
They want to set
up this for growth.
Right now, they have
five microservices.
They will have
more in the future.
Who reviews code when
you check code in?
Well, James has found a
cool feature in GitLab,
and it's in some
other tools, as well,
where you can add a
code owner's file.
That code owner's
file tells the system
who should be the auto-assigned
reviewers for any code that's
checked in.
And it also documents ownership.
If you're just
browsing the code you
know who to ask about a
particular piece of code.
Good.
They've decided to
go with monorepo.
First decision made,
one out of six done.
And it's time to
move on to number 2.
ADAM ROSS: So next, we
have continuous testing,
getting that test automation
going on an ongoing basis
so that every change is
carefully measured and found
to be acceptable
to move forward.
So junior developers
might commonly
think, oh, I can just
run the tests locally.
Everything will
work out just fine.
But more senior
engineers know that can
lead to inconsistently
running the tests and a lot
of difficulty making sure that
you're testing things the way
they operate in production.
Running end-to-end
tests on cloud services
can be a little
tricky on your laptop.
So they're going to
take their existing
work on building
their testing pipeline
and extend it to
these new serverless
services they've got.
And maybe some of those
automation engineers
amongst you would find
that fun, like Pari.
MARTIN OMANDER: It does sound
kind of fun, doesn't it?
I would want to build this.
ADAM ROSS: Yeah.
So here, we have the master
branch from the repo.
The master branch
is commonly used
as a release ready branch to
which all changes are merged.
Now, shortly after the last
release, a bug fix was begun.
This branch has been in
progress for a while,
but in the interim, someone else
came along, fixed a problem,
and merged that to master.
So when we look at
this bug fix branch--
ready to go, unit test passing.
James is excited to merge it.
Tess knows, wait a second.
Even though that test is
passing, it's showing green.
There is a logical
conflict between what
is now in master and the change
that James has been working on.
Thank goodness there
was an engineer on hand
that has memorized all
the code changes that
have gone on for the
last number of months.
So maybe the solution here
is to have trustworthy tests.
If your automated tests
aren't reliable pretty much
all the time, they're
not worth that much
because you learn to disregard
the results of running
those tests.
And so instead, we want to look
into continuous integration.
Continuous integration takes
this continuous testing idea
and focuses on how to make
sure that if you accepted
that change into your
main line of code,
would things still be passing?
This is done by merging
in the master branch
here into the bug fixed branch
before running those tests,
performing a code integration.
Not to be confused with
an integration test, which
is a bit of a different beast.
And as we explored, we're
needing to build that pipeline.
What kind of tools
should we use?
Well, one of the most
important features
that you might have
for your CI/CD system
would be a configuration
as code approach.
Having the definition
of those jobs
and all the operations committed
to your code repositories,
so that the entire development
team and any ops engineers,
and anyone else around that
technical neighborhood,
can see those changes and weigh
in on what they constitute
and make sure that
you're practicing
a good and integrated
DevOps sort of culture.
Now, as we've mentioned,
this team is using GitLab,
and they're going
to continue to use
that for these new services.
But in the future, maybe
they'll outgrow GitLab.
Maybe there'll be some
other considerations,
and they'll consider
other products,
such as CircleCI, Travis,
Jenkins, or Cloud Build, which
is a product in GCP.
A simple GitLab testing
pipeline is made of YAML.
I bet a lot of you here were
thinking, oh, serverless track.
We're safe from
YAML, but not always.
So here, we have a stage
that includes a test stage.
The only one for now, but
more will be added later.
And every single job in a
test stage runs in parallel.
And our initial jobs are
linting and unit testing.
Linting is checking
your code syntax
and unit tests are relatively
quick to run tests.
But we see that both of
these are running node.
They're both running
some implied service
that they're testing again.
So it's not necessarily a
good fit for a monorepo.
It's not testing a bunch
of different services.
So let's expand on
that linting job.
Now we have two linting jobs.
One is testing a node
service named relay,
running the job inside
the really subdirectory
of the repo, and
the other is linting
a service built in Go running
inside a payment subdirectory.
And as James is observing,
this multiplication of the jobs
is going to result
in some slowdown
as more and more services
are added to the repo.
And so making the pipeline
a bit more dynamic
is going to help that process.
Using almost any
CI/CD system, you
can introduce a
little dynamic logic
and take advantage of the
fact that you're probably
using version control.
And you can run slightly
complex commands,
such as this, this
git diff here,
to list all the files
that have changed.
Maybe only run the tests
that apply to those files.
And as it happens, GitLab
has a trick for that.
In the configuration, if you are
running your testing pipeline
for a merge request,
you can also
specify to only run that
job if a file changes
in a particular subdirectory.
So here, I see it is
configured to only run
if a file and the relay service
has some kind of update.
And you might be
thinking this is getting
a little complicated, but
that's a trade-off from going
with a monorepo.
The tooling is often a
little behind on that
compared to having a
service per repository.
Lastly, with the monorepo
and having all these services
in one repository, there
might be a tendency
to have some of the operations
leak into top level directories
or into this configuration file.
Well, having those operations
defined in the world's
best known task
runner, bash scripts,
you can get them isolated
into those same subdirectories
and make sure that those
responsible for an individual
service are also
responsible for all
the details of the operations.
And perhaps in the future,
this Into the Woods dev team
will look into to something
else that's a little bit more
sophisticated than bash,
maybe using make files
or Basil to run their jobs.
And so by the time all of
these steps are built in,
we have a few different stages
potentially coming together
on just the testing pipeline.
A pre-check here
is showing the use
of shellcheck, which is
a utility that applies
linting checks to bash scripts.
Then test, running
linting and unit tests
against each of the services.
And build, running any builds
for those services that
need a build process.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right, so
that was the end of step 2.
Now we're two down, four to go.
The next decision the team of
Into the Woods need to make
is how to manage
automatic deployment.
So there are a number of ways
to do deployments, all the way
from how CTO Sang did it before
he was a CTO, when he worked
in a startup 20 years
ago, through something
that a junior developer might
do with scripted development.
The team really,
though, they really
want to focus on continuous
deployment and delivery, rather
than these sort of
semi-manual approaches,
because that leads to the
more reproducible deployments
and higher velocity.
So James, he is a
happy junior developer.
He checks in a bunch of code.
It tests OK.
He merges them.
Ready to go on
the release train.
Let's deploy it and production.
Tess says, hold on a minute.
How do we know that
this won't break?
Pari has a solution.
We deploy it to staging, and
we deploy it all the time
to staging and keep
running tests there.
And that way, we can see if
it would break if we were
to deploy it to production.
Let's see what that
would look like.
ADAM ROSS: So adding deployment
to this whole pipeline
is really just adding
an additional stage
to the end of what
we've already built,
and that stage will include
some new deployment jobs.
These jobs bring with it
more YAML for us to look at.
A deployed job definitely needs
to run the deploy process,
and that will probably involve
using G Cloud, the command line
SDK that allows you to run
operations against GCP.
So we have a shorthand
authentication
for G Cloud to the
Cloud Platform,
and we'll go into more
detail on that later
in the security
section of the talk.
And then under the script,
we're changing directory
into the relay service, and
we're running our functions
deploy for that
Cloud Function, which
probably should be wrapped
in a deploy script itself.
But it's more clear this
way that that is not
a very complicated
script, necessarily.
Now, if you were going to
deploy instead a cloud run
service, which you
may have heard today
across the keynote
or other sessions,
you know that you're dealing
with serverless containers.
They have a bit of a
different deployment model.
And so you are deploying
a container image
from Google Container Registry
to your cloud run service.
But it is just the same,
a one-line command,
to make it happen.
So we have added the
new deployment jobs
to the end of our pipeline.
And so on every
change, it will run
through each of these
stages, ultimately
resulting in deployed code.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right,
three down, three to go.
The next step is environments.
How do we deal with
that at Into the Woods?
So just a quick reminder
what environments are.
We have the architecture.
That's the design, what computer
is in microservice, what
storage is in a microservice.
Environments-- those
are instantiations
of that architecture,
and we have them
for various uses, like
demo, and test, and so on.
All right, so the team
sits down to discuss this.
Pari says, let's
minimize administration
by having all these environments
live in one GCP project.
James is like, no.
Let's have them more isolated.
Let's have one environment
per GCP project.
We'll have many,
many, many projects.
Well, we need to look into the
pros and cons of each approach.
So if each environment
is a namespace,
here we have QA stage for
the payments microservice.
We have a Payments Compute
part and Payments Data
part for QA and for stage.
So only one project--
it has certain advantages.
Pari is right about that.
There is easy access management.
You go into IAM at
once and set that up.
It is also easy to just list
all your resources in a project,
because it's all right
there in one project.
However, there are some
global projects settings
that you might have seen
around regions and data,
App Engine data
store, and so on,
that we need set
once per project.
And that could be hard to
make all the environments use
those global settings.
Also, it's extra work to
connect the compute and the data
for these.
As a matter of fact, it could
get so bad that you crosswire
and there's crosstalk
between environments.
So the team decides not to have
everything in one giant GCP
project.
Well, the alternative
is every environment
is a separate GCP project.
So we have a staging project,
and we have a QA project.
So the disadvantage
of this is there
is more management, of course.
We need to set up user access
for every single project.
Another one is we have to keep
track of all these projects.
What's good about
this, though, is
that we have really strong
isolation with no crosstalk
between environments.
So the team decides to
go with this approach.
Now, the question is, how
do we avoid QA bottlenecks?
In the old pre-serverless
days in Into the Woods,
there was one QA environment.
And if you're
working on a branch,
you really wanted to
test your stuff on that,
and everybody was fighting
to get their stuff on there.
Well, new environments--
everything is serverless.
We can spin up as many
environments as we want, right?
Well, we do need to
keep track of them.
So maybe we should
give each developer
their own development
environment and their own QA
environment, rather than
infinite environments.
Let's see what that
would look like.
ADAM ROSS: So now that we
have a plan around the number
of environments, we have
production, staging, and then
a QA environment
for each developer,
and a development environment
so that they can experiment.
And each of these
environments is
related to the code
changes in some way.
Production is going to be tagged
off of the master branch when
releases are cut.
And master branch is going
to automatically deploy
the staging.
And then individual feature
branches will deploy to QA.
One of the challenges with
this arrangement of associating
different pieces,
different lines
of code to different
environments,
is how the CI/CD system
understands how to route that.
And for that, we have
a bit of bash magic.
Here, if the branch is master,
this first part of the code
says, oh, this
must be for stage.
And after the else
statement, we are looking up
a variable from the environment
to associate the developer that
pushed that last
change, and that
will map to that
developer's environment.
Now, you could hardwire
that and say, oh, we're
going to just use the
test environment today.
But by providing that
little bit of separation,
it provides space
to then continue
to expand this later to perhaps
have multiple environments that
could be routed to.
And so using this
arrangement, our earlier fix
to the master branch is
going to automatically deploy
to the staging environment.
And bug fix number
1, as it's going
through its
troubleshooting cycles,
will be deployed to
James's QA environment.
Once that is approved to
be merged into master,
it, too, will be
automatically deployed,
updating the staging environment
to the current picture of what
would happen if a production
release were tagged.
And of course, once
a release is tagged,
production will be deployed.
MARTIN OMANDER:
All right, the team
has decided on four out
of six decision points.
The next one is
serverless testing.
Now, this is a little
different than regular testing
if you're testing something
you run in your own data center
or on-prem.
Serverless is a little
bit of a different beast.
So there are, of course,
different types of testing.
Junior developers
think of units testing.
There's integration
testing, system testing.
Sang, the CTO, of
course, he thinks
more about end to end testing.
So we have this whole
spectrum of tests.
One isn't better than the other.
Some are really
useful to developers,
some are more useful
to business people.
We need a mix of all these
different types of testing.
How do we do that?
Well, so here, again,
we have bug fix 1,
the branch James has created.
He needs to merge this in.
Let's see what testing happens
at each place in this scenario.
So whenever he commits code--
that's the heart.
James loves his
code, it's a heart--
there is unit testing on
linting in the CI workspace.
So this still has nothing
to do with serverless,
or nothing to do with Cloud
Functions, or Cloud Run,
or anything like that.
It's auto-deployed, as we saw.
It's auto-deployed to james-qa.
This is James's
own QA environment.
And when it's
auto-deployed there,
the automatic system
tests are running there.
They run in the context of
serverless, so this run on GCP.
And you can use all the
GCP services and databases
and such.
They are more bigger
than unit tests.
Then when he merges
into master, there
are lint tests in
the CI/CD system.
And then it's all
deployed to staging.
Their system tests run,
just like on james-qa.
And there is also--
these more business-focused
end-to-end tests
are run in staging.
And there, all
branches are mixed up
in staging, too, so
we test all of them.
So broadly speaking,
there are two types
of testing environments here.
Inside the CI/CD system,
that's good for simple testing,
like unit tests and linting.
But when you
actually test stuff,
like server databases
and making calls,
and you're exercising
more of GCP,
then you actually need to
run those tests on GCP.
So there are very
serverless options.
You may know of serverless
functions, Cloud Functions.
You may know of App Engine.
And earlier today, you heard
about Cloud Functions--
sorry, Cloud Run.
Let's go through and
see how you would
test each one of these three
serverless computer options.
Testing Cloud Function,
you can do that locally.
There are various
ways of doing it.
We really recommend, if
you want to know more
about testing Cloud
Functions locally,
you should go to our
co-worker's, Stewart's talk,
on Thursday afternoon,
where he will dig
into more details around this.
For unit testing, you would
create mock HTTP requests.
And for system testing,
well, in that case,
you just you deploy to GCP.
You get the URL and then your
test system hits that URL.
Also worth noting
here, Tess notes
that it's good to have
more complex logic in sort
of secondary functions that
aren't directly called.
So that makes it easier
to just sort of test
those and troubleshoot
those in a local environment
before you deploy
everything up to GCP.
On App Engine, with the
modern runtimes on App Engine,
you do your local
development test,
using your regular tools or your
regular frameworks, whatever
you're using, Flask,
Express, et cetera.
Unit testing, there are mock
libraries that mock out,
like task, queues,
and databases,
and things like that.
And for system testing, it's
just like Cloud Functions.
You deploy it to GCP, you get
a URL and your test system
hits that URL.
Also worth noting here is that
App Engine has been around
for a long time.
So there is lots and lots
of content, lots of articles
and blog posts by
Googlers and non-Googlers
about how to test it.
That was two of the
serverless compute options.
What about the third one that
we heard about earlier today?
ADAM ROSS: Well, since
Cloud Run is new,
let's talk a little
about what it
is to set the groundwork
for how we would test in it.
Cloud Run bridges the worlds
of serverless and containers,
providing a way to run
a containerized service
serverlessly.
This means that you can
build a service in a pretty
conventional way, wrap it in
a container, and deploy it.
If you have no ops team, like
Tess's team seems to have,
you can use managed Cloud Run.
And otherwise, you can
have Cloud Run on GKE,
where you have a
Kubernetes cluster
underneath that your
own ops team can manage.
And with this arrangement,
all the considerations
of how you would test a
container come into play.
For local development
and debugging,
you might run your
service locally
using your standard
tools, or you
might choose to build that
container locally and run it
so that you are more closely
simulating the production
environment.
For unit testing, you
could also do the same,
run your unit tests the
way you normally would
when building code locally.
Or you might also
build a container
that's loaded up with a number
of development dependencies
on top of the same
production dependencies
that you have on
Cloud Run itself.
And in that case, you can
run the unit tests there
and have available
any of the system
packages or other
resources that are
part of your service container.
For system testing, much
as we were suggesting
with Cloud Functions
and App Engine,
go ahead and deploy your
service to Cloud Run.
It will only be running
when you're testing it,
and otherwise, it will scale to
0 and not cause you troubles.
With all of the
different jobs that we've
been looking at with
the CI/CD system,
there is this workspace
that is spun up,
in which we're running
the linting checks,
running unit tests, and running
G Cloud to trigger deployments.
And one of the
problems you might find
are the performance
concerns of what
it takes to initialize
that environment,
then run all the tests.
And waiting for tests
is kind of a bummer.
So one thing we can do is
find ways to optimize just how
big those workspaces are.
Can we use a smaller
container image
as part of that CI/CD workspace
to initialize the environment?
Now, if the main
Cloud SDK Docker
image that you might
use in a CI/CD workspace
is pretty fully loaded--
it's based on Debian,
it has a number of
emulators and other things
that you might not need
initially in a service.
So you might want to go with
a more stripped down approach,
using an Alpine-based image--
that's a lean
distribution of Linux
that's really popular
in containers--
and add to it just the pieces
you need, in this case,
for your Cloud Run work.
And so the team here has built
a slightly customized version
of the Cloud SDK, pulling
a static binary from Docker
for the Docker client,
and then adding that
to the official Alpine version
of the Cloud SDK Docker image,
and installing the
beta components, which
you need in order to interact
with the Cloud Run service.
This can lighten the size
of this workspace container
from around 700 megabytes
to 120 megabytes,
and that can save you a
good minute of download time
on each of those jobs.
Another problem that can emerge
from the particular way we've
outlined the system
here is the tendency
to only trigger the tests when
a developer takes an action.
For continuously evolving
software, that seems fine.
You'll trigger the tests
on an ongoing basis,
and they'll continually
be exercised.
But for a mature service
that has already been built
and is running happily
in the background,
without anyone the wiser, you
won't notice if bit rot sets in
and makes that service
unstable if you
were to try to deploy it
or try to issue changes.
And so rerunning the
deployment and testing process
on all your services
is a viable way
to make sure that they are all
staying in a healthy state,
whether or not developers
are actively working on them.
MARTIN OMANDER: So with
this, they've made decisions
in five out of the six areas.
They're almost there.
The CI/CD pipeline
is almost complete.
There is one area that is
very important you should not
forget about, of course--
that is security.
So the team sits down
to discuss security.
Pari notes that, for
her deployment scripts,
they need some secrets
to deploy to GCP.
Tess notes that are to hit the
payments API that the payment
provider, she needs an API key.
So here we see, right
away from the beginning
of the discussion,
two types of secrets.
We have operational
secrets, on one hand,
that deal with just managing
all the bills and CI/CD,
all that stuff.
And then we have
runtime secrets that
are used by the
runtime for when it
does what it's supposed to do.
At that point, James
comes in and says,
well, we have secure
source control.
This is not an open
source project.
Just deploy it all
to source control.
At this point, Pari has to
come in and gently guide
James and say that this
is not something one does.
There could be
accidental disclosure.
I mean, we don't want
developers to see the passwords
and then accidentally
enter it somewhere else.
We also have contractors
working from time to time
at Into the Woods.
Also, sometimes we share
code with other companies.
We could even have
people potentially break
into our source control system.
These secrets need
to be in a safer
place than source control.
How do we do this?
Pari has a proposal.
So let's manage the
operational secrets separately
from the runtime secrets.
So everything starts
with the repo, right?
We have the source code there.
Now, James, no secrets
in the source code.
Then that code gets pulled
in by the CI/CD system,
and the CI/CD system has the
operational secrets in it.
One operational secret is the
service key, service account
key.
That is used to
deploy code to GCP.
The other operational
secret is the name
of a storage bucket, that
Google Cloud Storage bucket.
And that is deployed, or set,
as an environment variable
in the runtime environment so
the runtime environment can
read it.
What does the
runtime environment
do with the name of
the storage bucket?
Well, when it needs a
secret, like the API
key for the payment API,
it can go and hit that,
read from that Cloud
Storage bucket,
and get that runtime secret.
And what's cool about this
is that now that reading
of the runtime secret is managed
through IAM in GCP, which
means it can be really
locked down, who can read it.
James can't read
it, for example.
Pari can't read it.
Maybe none of the
developers can read it.
Maybe it's only the CTO,
Sang, who can read it,
and the runtime environment.
So setting up this environment
means operational secrets,
runtime secrets separately.
Let's talk about how
those operational secrets
are put into the CI/CD system.
In GitLab, it's easy.
You just enter
them in the web UI.
This means there is
no file sitting around
with these secrets.
As soon as you have a
file, it's very dangerous
because somebody might
accidentally check it in.
In this way, somebody
types them into the web UI.
Nobody saves them anywhere.
Once you type these in,
let's see where they go next.
ADAM ROSS: So if we look
at the particular variables
we have here, the third one
down is the service account key.
This is a key associated with
a service account from IAM.
And it's been entered here
in a base64 encoded way.
That way, if anyone
accidentally looks at it,
takes a screenshot, echoes
it goes out to terminally,
they have not
accidentally seen it.
It's a nice security
through obscurity.
And so using that, every single
job that runs in the CI/CD
system can then
expand on that key,
taking that
environment variable,
decoding it, and then using
that to authenticate G
cloud so that it
can go on, pretend
to be that service account
as it goes through and runs
any deployment or other
commands that you need to run.
Now, as Pari notes here,
you might find that this
is a little bit easier if you
were running from Cloud Build,
because with Cloud
Build, instead
of needing to manage
this key separately,
you can instead grant
permissions to the Cloud
Service account directly and
it will operate with that,
no additional keys needed.
So once you have
this service account,
what exactly do
you do to give it
those accesses, all
the permissions that it
needs to run builds
and deployments
and perform other operations?
You could give it the
project owner or editor role.
That's the easy
button way to do it.
But in that case, if anything
were to expose that key,
the blast radius of that
would be encompassing almost
all the things that can be
done with your GCP project.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Yeah, some could just
take down the production
environment with that key,
right?
ADAM ROSS: It could
just delete it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Delete it, ew.
ADAM ROSS: So Instead, a
least privilege approach
is much better.
Figure out exactly which
roles and Cloud Storage bucket
ACLs you need to have and assign
them to the service account.
That way, you know that you've
got the minimum exposure.
What's more, since we've
charted this course
of every environment
being its own GCP project,
we might want to have a
central repository for things
like build artifacts and
this service account,
so that we can have one
central source of authority
and then deploy into each
of those other environments.
In that case,
we're going to need
to collect all of the
different roles and permissions
for the deployment process
of shipping resources,
shipping Cloud Functions
into stage and production,
and give that to the service
account on a cross project
basis.
This can be done by
identifying the email address
of the service
account and adding it
like a normal user
to other projects.
For runtime secrets,
we've charted
this course of using
a Cloud Storage
bucket as a kind
of vault, switch
we are going to have the
runtime function look up
and pull in the
secrets as needed.
Here, we have a little bit of
bash magic in the first couple
lines of the slide, which is
looking up a Cloud Storage
bucket that is specific
to an environment,
using a little trick for a
dynamic variable names in bash.
This bucket name is then passed
into the Function, or Cloud Run
service, or App Engine
app when you deploy it,
so that when those things start
up, they can load the secret
and keep it in memory to
reuse for further requests
in the future.
Now, with all this talk of
giving permissions and roles
to a service account with keys
exported to another system,
there's a lot of access
that you're still
exposing, even
though you're trying
to get a least access approach.
Being able to
deploy to production
is not a trivial thing.
And there are a number of
ways you might approach that.
Since we're using
GitLab, you might
take the OpenSource version of
GitLab and host that on GKE.
I believe there's a code lab
session for that on Thursday,
exploring how to do that.
But one approach that Pari
and the Into the Woods team is
exploring here is splitting up
the responsibilities of what
different systems will do.
GitLab can be responsible
for everything up to QA,
and maybe Cloud Build will
handle all the operations
for staging and production.
Since so many of our operations
are wrapped up in bash scripts,
they can be easily
executed by any runner.
And so GitLab is
going to perform
the same operations
as Cloud Build
through the lens
of those scripts.
And so as we've built out
the additional stages,
we might even add deployment
and an acceptance stage
for those end to end tests.
Let's go ahead and see if that
demo from the start of the talk
has completed and we have a
successfully deployed service.
So here is the
GitLab CI pipeline
that we started earlier.
And now we see we have
some green checkboxes.
And the last one here,
with the exclamation mark,
looks like an accepted failure.
But I'm not too worried
about that right now.
I want to see, did
my QA environment
get updated from this change?
And looking into this terminal
output from the CI system,
it looks like it ran
through all the steps,
figured out an environment, and
deployed to a demo environment.
And here, we have a URL to
look at our cloud run service.
Well, that command
disappeared, didn't it?
Well, since Cloud
Run services deploy
in an authenticated
only way, and I
don't have that command
handy, we will move on.
Go back to the slides, please.
Take it away.
MARTIN OMANDER:
All right, so now
that they have the whole CI/CD
pipeline set up, what have
they learned along the way?
Well first, Junior James,
he was a bit concerned
about this CI/CD, there will
be a lot of bureaucracy.
He's happy that CI/CD
actually helps him.
Pari, who writes a
lot of these scripts,
she sees that monorepo, that
adds complexity in the scripts,
but it is worth it.
Also, secrets management
is always tricky.
Tess notes that serverless
makes the CI/CD easier
because you can
test in environments
that are exact carbon copies of
your production environments.
And also, those environments
don't cost anything
if they are not running.
Finally, Sang is really happy
that they can release software
more predictably.
[MUSIC PLAYING]